all right well mother nature unleashed
the winds that's for sure they've been
around since yesterday 30 35 miles an
hour even higher in the mountains boy
you can really see that layer of smoke
out there can't you the sun is just now
above it and those winds are still
blowing out of the south southwest and
we're a little bit drier i think you're
going to notice that immediately when
you step outside 46 mile an hour winds
up at kyle canyon 62 miles an hour up at
angel peak a little higher boulder city
32 mccarran 30 red rock 30. so we've had
a lot of neighborhoods that have had 25
to 30 mile an hour winds those are just
some of the highest lots of 80s this
morning but again dew points right
around 50 so it's just a little bit
drier in humidity around 30 percent
outside the valley upper 70s in front
this morning near 80 in indian springs
82 in searchlight 88 in laughlin we
still have the wind advisory for the
lake in the river today until seven
o'clock tonight so expecting some strong
gusty winds there look at the 50s up in
reno and ely it's all with a system
that's bringing in much cooler air and
i'll show it to you in a minute let's
talk about the smoke it's still around
obviously we're seeing it more wildfires
in california and more smoke too and a
lot of it's being brought southward with
this system that's moving through the
great basin and that's why it's going to
be around in our area today tomorrow and
maybe just around at times especially
when the winds settle down it just kind
of sinks and sits around in our air lots
of leftover flooding from the remnants
of fred showers and thunderstorms in the
southern plains today and these are all
flash flood watches across the northeast
there's been a lot of flooding with
heavy rain as well as tornadoes from
fred and i'm looking at tornado boxes
right there in parts of the eastern ohio
valley so this is an area of low
pressure that's more like a fall weather
pattern really than late summer lots of
showers and thunderstorms through utah
and arizona
where flash flood watches have been
issued in those areas that wind advisory
in effect as i said east of las vegas
along the river and out at the lake
until seven o'clock tonight now we're
going to have sunshine and smoke and
wind for the first part of the day and
then that low kind of gets close to us
and may bring us a chance of late day
thunderstorms into tonight
definitely a cooling trend as we'll see
temperatures might not even make it to
100 degrees today and look at the mid
90s tomorrow friday saturday hang onto
90s so again a slight chance of
thunderstorms into tonight and then
we're back to clear skies and the heat
returns next week but